Okay.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P you
know, I've had people cancel memberships or
stop watching because I took the wrong political
position.
I've had people cancel memberships or stop
watching because they don't like the format
of the show or the frequency with which we
produce programming or whatever.
I'm not aware of anyone who has stopped watching
the show because they found out my sexual
orientation.
But it sounds like that's what we have here.
Take a listen to this.
Uh, yeah, mr [inaudible].
Uh, I'm not a solicitor or anything.
I'm just a regular viewer.
I've been watching you for awhile and I totally
thought you were gay and I was really liking
everything that you said.
I agree with everything, but dude, you know
I'm gay.
Totally thought you were gay.
So it just kinda crushed me when I kind of
found out that you weren't.
So I wish, and maybe I'll listen.
Maybe I will, but I always had a high hope
that you were, yeah.
Thanks a lot, man.
You're good.
But
well, that's a shame.
I mean, I don't know why it would be such
a [inaudible].
I don't know how it affects your experience
watching or listening to the show that you
thought I was gay and I'm not, and now you're
disappointed.
But I have actually, the only interesting
thing about this is that, right?
Like I don't care.
It doesn't bother me whether someone miss
assesses my sexual orientation.
It's really not a big deal.
You know, I think we all are making evaluations
of people we meet all the time about different
characteristics.
Really doesn't bother me.
One bit.
My question is why is the show less interesting
if I'm not a gay guy?
That is really the question I would like to
see answered sooner than later.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I'm back on the bonus show.
Pat did a great job the last few days filling
in for me on the bonus show.
I will be back today we will talk about a
showdown about LGBTQ employment rights that
is heading to the Supreme court.
We will talk about a local story here in the
Boston area and national grid employee has
been fired.
Uh, it was a Trumpist wearing a Trump hat
who confronted a woman in nearby Belmont over
her bumper stickers.
We will also talk about the disturbing rise
of deep fake videos online.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, and remember this weekend, massive membership,
fun drive.
If you want to support the show, you want
to do it at the lowest rate of the year.
We are doing a one day membership special
this weekend.
People will be notified by email.
Get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com
you will get an email this weekend with a
one day opportunity to cash in on an extremely
inexpensive membership for the year.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].